okay um
let's go for another game fritz car
2280 from um
from the united states
go for kings indian and um
okay try some
sideline the other bug
so still interesting
okay
yeah i cannot really take on h6 now
because of knight takes e4
takes and then queen h4 getting the
the pawn back so i need to to drop this
bishop back
now is interesting position i've tried
g4 here
okay he's aware of the the right setup
black needs to really do something like
h5
and now he's um going for counterplay
there yeah
okay
need to rearrange pieces some
somehow this um
bishop is really silly placed
maybe to d1
or d3 okay
we need to speed up
i find it somewhat
unsettling that he plays this so quickly
it's really a sideline
a4 trying to stop b5 but it looks a bit
artificial here
my position not sure if i like it
okay
maybe knight h7 or something could be an
idea okay he's playing
most straightforward fashion
maybe trying to
get to d3 or something okay but this is
this is a normal move anyway
maybe i'm trying to provoke um a move of
the h
pawn here okay he's i don't know what
he's doing but
not the moves i'm expecting i don't
understand this move
frankly what's what's the point
knight b3 okay i'll take on h5
can't be too bad to open up the g4 b5
supports the idea okay
okay okay b5
okay let's take this
of course knight d3 threatened now
okay i grabbed this one
and now the question is what's what
about a5
if i take just a5
uk has got to check on d3 but if i go to
f1
says this is difficult or what
okay i grab this pawn
check
the queen is attacked so he doesn't have
a good discovery i think and
uh after this i just saw it bishop e2
and
i didn't see a move
what's what is he playing now
besides i don't know yeah this is the
stupid move maybe yeah
okay let's take him
and now i'm yeah one maybe two pawns up
i could take on g6 now
let's play h6
this looks even even more inconvenient i
think
okay what's this this
i've got a mouse slip yeah the only way
to lose this game is a mouse slip
against
this peep terrible
this was just completely winning and he
played like a complete
i don't know i'm sorry i'm sorry
but i just i just i just hate it i think
i i need to switch off the smart move
let's resign here white resigns
this is just a complete joke i take i
can just retake here
with with the within knight he needs to
drop the bishop to h8
and i play knight c3 and it just resigns
completely over it's got a dead piece on
h8 i've got two extra pawns
b pawn is just running and then
i somehow touched the h3 square
yeah maybe i just switched that off it's
just too terrible
because it tends to happen
somehow in completely winning positions
okay let's let's try a new game